inflation is at a 40-year high in the
united states and most market commentary
is focused on things like supply chain
disruptions geopolitical conflict and
other easy to blame causes but most
folks they don't actually acknowledge
that market intervention is one of the
leading causes of inflation
we had historic monetary stimulus in
2020 and 2021 and that led to historic
inflation but this is not a new concept
milton friedman the well-respected
economist and nobel prize winner
famously said inflation is always and
everywhere a monetary phenomenon in the
sense that it is and can be produced
only by a more rapid increase in the
quantity of money than an output this
idea of a monetary phenomenon is
something that milton friedman talked
about often here's a video of him from
decades ago talking about why inflation
is created in washington
inflation is made in washington because
only washington can create money
and any other attribution of two other
groups of inflation
is wrong
consumers don't produce it
producers don't produce it
the trade unions don't produce it
foreign sheiks don't produce it
oil imports don't produce it what
produces it is too much government
spending and too much government
creation of money and nothing else
don't take milton friedman's word for it
though if we go ahead and we take the m2
money supply and we lay it over the
actual inflation rate what we see is
that the m2 money supply explodes
upwards and shortly after we continue to
see higher inflation
but if we take a look deeper at that m2
money supply over the last 25 years the
name of the game has been create more
money and if we zoom in here on the last
five years we can see that the problem
is only getting worse and more magnified
there's no secret that the covet 19
pandemic led to government mandated
lockdowns which led to a liquidity
crisis and the velocity of money
dropping and so the government whether
right or wrong they decided to step in
and use monetary stimulus to get asset
prices and markets recovered but as
milton friedman also pointed out the
government solution to a problem is
usually as bad as the problem itself
that sounds eerily accurate given the
current situation that we're facing
as we look at the bureau of labor
statistics data we can see that the cpi
metric continues to accelerate moving
from about five and a half percent in
june of 2021 to now over 9
in june of 2022 but contrary to popular
belief disinflation is not the fault of
millennials it's also not the fault of
boomers or any other generation either
milton friedman knew this he's a very
interesting person to pay attention to
because he understood inflation
intimately he had a number of different
warnings that he issued over the years
and he even predicted environments like
we're living through right now one of
his most famous points was that
inflation is taxation without
legislation it simply steals from the
bottom 50 or so of americans and you
have no say there's no ability to vote
those who created it out of office and
you simply have to watch as your wealth
and your economic value is eroded away
by an invisible threat milton friedman
also has one of my favorite quotes ever
in this one he states
when government in pursuit of good
intentions tries to rearrange the
economy legislate morality or help
special interests the costs come in
inefficiency lack of motivation and loss
of freedom
government should be a referee
not an active player
now what we have watched is that central
banks and elected officials they can't
simply sit by and be the referee they've
been dying to be an active player
they've manipulated interest rates down
and now they're manipulating them back
up they were asset buyers with a
persistent bid in the market for years
and now they claim that they're going to
be an asset seller they're going to
shrink the federal reserve's balance
sheet
regardless of whether you believe them
or not what we are watching is that more
intervention equals more problems the
free market is smarter than politicians
we should allow the free market to work
milton friedman warned us about high
inflation and the problems that come
from market intervention
in fact
friedman didn't just warn us he
predicted this he saw what happens when
central banks can't simply help
themselves when they continue to
increase the monetary supply
and they don't allow for demand to catch
up
what we have lived through over the last
two years was an insane undisciplined
monetary and fiscal policy regime
and demand didn't grow fast enough
instead we are left with an ever
increasing monetary supply and now we
have historically high inflation
since 40 years ago we haven't seen
inflation like this
we have major problems in this country
and abroad
and unless central bankers and
politicians learn to stay out of the
market to allow the free market to do
its thing
we are only going to keep kicking the
can down the road and introducing more
and more problems milton friedman won
the nobel prize for a reason he
understood economics he understood free
markets and he understood inflation
it's about time that we start paying
attention to the lessons that he taught
us decades ago
because they're ever as relevant today
as they were back then